[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever we
want so anthony he was yeah he was just
telling us
first of all he was he was uh sending uh
his driver's license
i was handling a little bit of a visa
thing uh
i am hopefully going to china next week
why would you want to go where the the
epicenter of coronavirus is very elegant
china it is technically safer than
america right now probably okay facts
uh is it because you have kenja studios
over there and you're working with the
enemy
wow that's a very shot i am the enemy
i'm just kidding
cause dance you're no you're an
ambassador because you're trying to
bring us together with dance
yeah i like that they're trying to save
the us rec center yeah
i'm working on an artist's tour i don't
know if i'm gonna talk about but i am
working on an artist tour some
choreographer for artists out there with
my
with my brother ving from the kinjaz and
uh so i gotta go over there to see the
tour
you know through which starts in
december and um
which means i'm already really really
late because we have
had really really hard times trying to
secure a visa in order for
myself to go there that really has been
already over there it really really
sucks
it's been already over there no he's not
he's really really here really really
wide
because uh i really really need to work
on this project but
are you guys really really blocked
though like are they like no america
no it's not it just depends on who gives
you your invitation letter or like what
type of business
you're saying you're well connected you
i'm saying i wish i was more well
connected because then
i wouldn't be in the last minute
situation than i am right now
for example uh mike song actually just
came back from china he was there for a
month
working on a two-week job but had a
two-week quarantine it was actually him
and his wife out there
oh nice yeah so they were working on the
league of legends world finals that just
happened over there
wow and then but like they were able to
scare visa because of the company that
was bringing them out
but i wasn't able to because of maybe
either the business purpose or the
connections that i had so it was just
like he's more famous
he's more famous he's always better i
mean i know he was on ellen and all that
he's super famous yeah but what he had
to do was
do two weeks of quarantine he's a
quarantine and then he worked for two
weeks
so even him and his wife were in the
same like quarantine hotel but in like
different rooms
why all right he's not that famous yeah
yeah
yeah what is the point i should be
bumping uglies during this quarantine am
i right
fives to geo i'm like what's the point
you're there with your wife
you have two weeks no responsibilities
you're not to work you should be 69 in
every chance
24 7 69.
seven days a week seven days a week well
that's too much math 25
8. um but yeah cool guys that's probably
the only thing that i'm uh
it's probably the only thing that i'm
not looking forward to but at the same
time looking forward to because i feel
like it's going to be a lot of suffering
and loneliness for me
um in a weird way so you like suffering
and learning no i just feel like
everybody's got to go through like
intense things in order to kind of
discover who they are
oh you're saying your life is really
good so stupid is that stupid well
what do you think you're going to do for
that 14 days like that's probably the
hardest lots of masturbation
depending on the wi-fi you got a vpn you
got a good vpn
what if you get no wi-fi wow
magazines they still exist dude what's
the porn like in china i'm just curious
because like you know vpn problems oh
cause they just i like these vessels
they pixel out everything don't they i
went through the rabbit hole of watching
um chinese guys [ __ ] hotel rooms
try it wait why you guys don't go down
that stuff you watch it for the guys
no no no i mean like they weren't porn
stars it was like i just wanted to paint
a picture of like guys
and girls like [ __ ] in a hotel room
but like they're probably prostitutes is
it hitting camera
because the girls were way out of their
league oh wow
yeah maybe they were porn so i don't
think i'm going to have access to
prostitutes in my 14-day quarantine yeah
probably not and that's not really cool
with the quarantine thing
like you know what i mean like unless
they come in and hazmat suits and like
did somebody order skye and taste
i'm sorry i don't know where that came
from that was an odd accent dude you
older the scientist that's the one
okay scientist that's pretty good okay i
didn't get it at first
okay so what's the process you you if
you get to go right how do they
quarantine you
how do they keep so so first i had to
get secure
an invitation letter and then now i can
uh apply for a visa after like the
consulate kind of like approves like the
time frame that i'm like requiring
or asking to go there and then from
there if i get approved by the consulate
and they accept my visa application
i have to find which flight i want to
get on because the flight won't allow me
to purchase the ticket
unless i do a two-step corona virus test
40 within 48 hours of getting on the
plane a lot of timing
wait really what is that so so the two
step is is either uh is both
the nasal uh swab uh and also now an
antibiotic one where
they draw your blood i like that i think
have you done both no actually i'm about
to have you done any of them
no because you know why my girlfriend
nina she works in a uh she was doing
telehealth during this time frame of the
pandemic so she had to
also still go get tested every single
week and then when she went into she was
also working at the woman's uh
downtown women's center as well doing
like clinical stuff and she also still
had to get tested every week so
literally every single week she was
tested so i was like
you must be tested too i must be solid
it's kind of like with your sex partner
yeah if you only have one and they went
to the gyno i'd be like
did you get tested it's like yes let's
make out all right cool you good
only the girl ever needs to ever need to
get tested guys don't need to get tested
you don't ever get sex
tested i just got tested that's good
that's good i do the home tests
for stds baby after every new partner
you that's the
that's what they recommend and that's
what they teach you
in sexual education at school
unless you go to a school that just says
be abstinent
yeah if you are saying you only do at
home std test
how does that work no i'm doing that now
because of quarantine but it's
i would i don't know would you rather i
used to go to planned parenthood what do
you do how does it work
you just [ __ ] pee in a tube well okay
so the one i do is like you get a uh
you get a peepee tube like a pee pee cup
and then you pee pee in that cup
and then you get a uh a a squeezer thing
and then you take your peepee and you
put it in the tube and then you close it
you put in the bag
and then you drop it off to 24 uh
overnight
ups you ups your urine
yeah dude it's a prepaid label oh snap
yeah i thought it was going to be one of
those like healthy drop box metal things
but you could check like you're corona
like this too like there's companies
that
have home kits they're fda approved like
you just [ __ ] do the swappy swab
yourself you [ __ ] put your uh q-tip
inside of a test tube send that
[ __ ] out there's ones where you
draw your blood and they see if you have
testosterone or not
and if you're a little [ __ ] you can
even ship your breast milk
to yeah like if like i have a kid and
i'm breastfeeding but i
leave the country or state or whatever
they'll deliver it that's pretty cool
same day or overnight or some [ __ ]
what's the name of the service titty
express
shout out to the titty express promo
code off the record
that's a good business name that's great
they have great t-shirts too yeah
but i know those 24-hour tests they were
like
a grand oh not 24 but the same day like
you go
in and you just get that's a good
there's one in beverly hills
where you just do one because you know
how like when this first started i was
like well i need to
go but when i come back i need to
quarantine
and all this stuff so i was like how do
i like make sure that
you know and i looked for one and that
was it i recently saw the video
of of like the early corona test where
they stick it all the way in because i
had heard about it but i didn't actually
see
it happen yeah and that [ __ ] i was like
oh my god
those are your brains and they're like
it was like this long
and then it like went all the way up in
there it looks like it's going to go
through your skull that's how far it
goes from the bottom
yeah that was painful to watch i can't
even imagine what it felt like where do
you get a 48 hour
test like you one of those same day test
centers and then as soon as you get it
you get on your flight right
once it says that i don't have the virus
i can purchase the ticket with my test
results and then from there i have to
get on the plane and when i get on the
plane and i go over there
i i get quarantined for 14 days how
annoying yeah yeah
like you literally cannot leave the
hotel room
that's stupid because what if you bought
the ticket with your test results
and then your ticket was scheduled a
month later
no no like especially because of the
pandemic situations i think that there
are available seats constantly so like
this is a system that's being put in
place for certain like countries and
whatnot
wow that's crazy because in hawaii is 72
hour test if you
if you arrive at the airport with a 72
hour like a test within 72 hours right
then you show the proof they'll be like
okay you could come in without
quarantine
so for that one though you can buy your
ticket ahead of time
and then you just have to show up with
your test results and that's when they
let you on the plane because here
yeah i don't think i can buy the ticket
until i show proof of the uh the test
results
damn does that mean the tickets are more
expensive because they're like
they're super expensive right now
definitely super like probably like
uh maybe like 500 600 like more than
they
normally would have 100 because you know
i went to denver and it was about 60
dollars
for a round-trip ticket nice well when
we're talking about like international
in-state i just wanted to flex a little
bit that was a good flight yeah 60
dollars
that's a good burn yeah
[Music]
but the return was delta
was that 60 bucks though all right yeah
no it's it's it's round trip so the the
the two you're reflecting because you
got that special little friend thing
no no no but the spirit of delta i
bought it this is
not working i bought it no flex dude
that's
cheap still but they're coming back i
had to pay for my luggage
no flex that's tight but you know what
though uh this video is brought to you
by
feels and i'd be experiencing stress my
friends don't
believe me that i can get really good
discounts
i get a lot of anxiety i get [ __ ]
stressed out but also
traveling sometimes can get a little
hectic especially in times of corona
because
i risk my life to fly and you're going
to be doing that too going to the
the birthplace of corona right and since
we're all going to be worrying
and stressed out for uh uh uh
worrying about our good friend anthony
here i think
a good solution sometimes might be
certain cbd oil such as feels
because that's what i use to chill the
hell out fields is a premium cbd
delivered directly to your doorstep
feels naturally helps reduce stress
anxiety pain and sleeplessness before i
take flights i just go
and i drip a few in my mouth and i
relaxanate and it really helps me just
knock the hell out when i'm on a plane
place a few drops under your tongue and
feel the difference within minutes
the thing to remember about cbd is that
finding your right dose is important
and every dose is different so leave
room to experiment over the course of a
week or so so you may need to take
more or less to get the effects you're
after so
new to cbd fuels offers a free cbd
hotline to help guide your personal
experience
fields works naturally to help you feel
better there's no high hangover or
addiction
join the fields community to get fields
delivered to your door every month
you'll save money on every order and you
can pause or cancel anytime
feels has me feeling my best every day
and it can help you to become a member
today by going to feels.com
off the record and you'll get 50 percent
off your first order
with free shipping that's f e a l s dot
com slash off the record
to become a member and get 50
automatically taken off your first order
with free shipping
fields.com off the record thank you very
much fields
is cbd legal in china you think
i wonder if they even know what it is i
don't know when was the last time you
were in china
january wow i was literally in china and
i was
leaving china the day that wuhan got
locked down
oh so we were brought back oh no
i think we found out that i didn't about
like nine ten months ago
who knows you know yeah yeah but that
being said it could have been stuck in
your hair
yeah you don't know everything i don't i
don't you're absolutely
right have you ever done the antibody
test
no i haven't i want to do it yeah
because then that's how you'll for sure
can you tell us if you do
i am about to okay but doesn't it go
away in like three months though
if you test positive for that type of
rooms in your system
right my bad i always get that confused
no they were saying like you could
you could have antibodies for like three
months and then you could just not have
them anymore what
yeah stop my buddy fauci seriously
i can't keep up why don't you be saying
some crazy [ __ ] it's my boy dude
first he was like don't worry about the
mask and then he was like oh [ __ ] we
need the mask so i'm like what is he
what so well now they're like if it's
okay to go vote
i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah really that's what
they said if you have corona you can go
vote
yep i don't like that you're good
anthony you're good all i'm saying is
like for example my boy michael who just
was in china he was
able to go to our king's dojo out there
at the studio have a full class
people weren't wearing masks but you
guys even wear masks like even
pre-corona though yeah we do
but i'm just saying the dancers like in
the studio things were like at such a
level of normalcy that people like you
know post dance classes they were like
sweaty and like still like hugging
they're saying what's up a great job or
whatnot oh cool
and mike was literally like blown away
because he was just like i was just gone
for 40 [ __ ] days by myself he has a
full-on beard
but then he comes back and then he comes
back to a world in america where
everything is yeah confusing and weird
again does america make him quarantine
when he comes back no
he said when he got off the plane and he
when he got off the plane in china
uh at the airport the way that things
were like set up and like the way that
everything was so secure and like
things were blocked off so there was
only one way to go and the way that
everything was just organized it was
like you went into a different planet
that was like clearly like
post-apocalyptic
but then he said the weirder thing was
come back home to this like
ironic normalcy everybody just kind of
freely walking around touching things
not really caring it's almost like
normal disorderly conduct it's like no
wonder we're number one right now yeah
but we obviously still have like the
high school so for them
it's like you get to mars and then they
separate you
and then they kind of make sure that
you're clean and then they
let you into the public and you're good
so then it's like a bubble you're like
eating in restaurants with other people
like it's yeah take that that makes
sense though yeah
that kind of does make sense it's what
people should be doing
14 days of really uh
really really weird uh quarantine
lifestyle and like just kind of being
lonely and suffering and then having
normal life
versus constantly 24 7 here in the u.s
of i don't knows makes sense yeah it
seems like like the nba bubble right
that's what they all did yeah
and they were able to obviously it's a
lot smaller scale but in theory
if everyone everybody gets weeded out
yeah then it should be fine which is
pretty
much why that was the only one that was
able to kind of work right
that's crazy damn dude we got absolutely
14 days
super weird that was the intention of
the beginning of the quarantine though
right like if everybody would have just
like kind of followed it like
by logic yeah yeah science like
it should kind of just mellow out it's
supposed to it was supposed to
like flatten the curve is what they said
right and then it was supposed to go
away but there's a good one they were
just doing it like
like sectors and counties and states and
some people there's something
disorganized
yeah but you know you go to this like
maybe giant communist country type of
like you know scale and
you get 1.4 billion people to be like
stay home
don't do this wear masks only blah blah
everybody has to otherwise you like go
to jail
yeah i remember in the early
right i remember when we were first like
reporting about coronavirus before we
even had our lockdown i remember
like way back then that we were all
laughing in this room about the fact
that china were they were using drones
to keep people inside their house we're
like oh my god
that's [ __ ] crazy that's ridiculous
and then now we're like oh [ __ ] they
were doing the right drones might be a
good idea
maybe we should have drones flying
around we do they just like murder
people in other countries exactly
[Laughter]
i just want the drones with the speakers
on i'm telling us to go back in oh
sorry those ones those ones yeah skynet
got it
that's pretty weird man this guy's good
damn
that's crazy i don't know man so like
okay in between all of this have you
left the u.s no i haven't this is the
first time
in like years that i've just like been
at home consistently
but i mean we all this this ain't even
about me like all of us went through
freaking a lockdown for like the first
time ever
like that's like a global wide one who
traveled the furthest here
away from home you did i mean the east
coast
yeah yeah well you were in like europe
during the whole lockdown yeah i was in
europe you were like trying to get back
i almost missed the last flight yeah
that was crazy
oh as i was on the train the borders
were closing
that's crazy this is like the second
time a big event happened where you
almost didn't make it because i think
you were barely leaving japan when that
big tsunami hit it
all right that is crazy actually we were
so
scared for him yeah but he was already
on the flight back i'm like the guy
that's like
buildings are blowing up behind me and i
just constantly superhero
[ __ ] tom cruise and mission
impossible
but it's like happening with me not even
knowing
oh [ __ ] mr magu dude you're walking
around
that is crazy i do think that
yeah it is disjointed because just me
traveling and like going out to
different states
um they treat it differently a lot of it
a lot of
different even counties people are like
yeah don't worry about masks here
and other places are like oh you got to
have your masks on yeah
it's weird confusing it is confusing
yeah
cause like in l.a county all theaters
indoor theaters are all closed
but then in oc you you can go to them
so you could watch a movie in oc and
then come back home to l.a yeah i wanted
to watch tennis so i went to san diego
oh nice i was thinking about that yeah
yeah let's try it it was
pretty fun i know someone that drove to
vegas and he did that and i made fun of
him for doing that
wow good for you vegas is too far yeah
you could have done this it's not that
far
we just drove to huntington beach and
watched it yesterday
we said what we just watched yesterday
yeah
oh we should talk about it
[Music]
entire yes room just for like his party
so it was only two four six eight of us
yeah i have to say though i don't know
where to begin if you were to talk about
it don't talk about it
that shit's confusing the whole point is
you can begin at the end
oh very true all right good point do you
see that christopher nolan right
he went to smuggle himself to san diego
to watch it
mm-hmm good thing he'd go to vegas
because that would have been there's
nothing wrong with vegas
no it's not but if you drive to vegas to
go see a movie i'm going to make fun of
you we almost did but if you go to san
diego that's fine we drove to san diego
just to get tacos
multiple times that makes sense
different okay okay
all right then i get it i have weird
like rules in my head about like what's
okay
so food is okay but not a movie ah well
if
you know who this person was then you'd
be like this [ __ ] jerk
you guys know gilbert from yeah tiger
belly [ __ ] silver
oh boo gilbert yeah that's that's who it
was
you don't know what we're talking about
can't stand this guy dude
you